nachfragen an alexander kissler vom
berliner büro der neuen zürcher zeitung
ich grüße sie
schüttelt morgen aus berlin herr kessler
die union samt ihrem kanzlerkandidaten
im sinkflug die spd mit scholz im
steigflug lässt sich dieser trend mit
diesem zukunftsteam whistler statt jetzt
präsentiert hat aufhalten oder gar
umkehren
das ist die hoffnung der cdu als
betreuer das beobachte man muss
natürlich zunächst mal sagen der mikado
wahlkampf wer sich bewegt er verliert
ist zunächst einmal vorüber laschet hat
vielleicht am letztmöglichen zeitpunkt
begriffen dass er selber aktiv werden
muss dass ihm das kanzleramt nicht in
den schoß fällt wenn sie mich nun direkt
zu den zukunftsteam fragen muss man
sagen es ist solide es zeigt dass er
verantwortung auf mehreren schultern in
welche administrativ in form auch immer
verteilen will aber es ist jetzt keine
achter personengruppe wo man mit der
zunge schnalzen und sagt ob all das
hätte ich nicht gedacht dass er einen so
tollen experten bekommt markus söder
nennt ja die aktuellen umfragewerte der
union alarmierend erfordert vollgas vor
allem natürlich von armin laschet und
verspricht achtung hundertprozentige
rückendeckung
die ziehen auch so so dass worte
vernimmt man wohl allein es fehlt der
glaube
ich freue mich immer wenn goethe zitiert
wird oder in diesem fall stimmt das
natürlich völlig so der versucht schon
etwas sich zu exkulpieren von der
verantwortung für eine drohende
wahlniederlage nach dem motto es hat
dann doch an dem gelegen was ich immer
befürchtet habe an der mangelnden
akzeptanz von armin laschet in der
bevölkerung an seinem mangelnden
kampfeswillen an seiner mangelnden
vertrauenswürdigkeit das heißt es ist
ein sehr sehr vergiftetes lob und er
will sagen um ein weiteres zitat zu
bringen ich war schon meine hände in
unschuld wenn es schief geht nun
versuchen dass beide sagen wir mal auf
den letzten metern dieses wahlkampfs
immer offensiver mit warnungen vor einem
linksbündnis ja ist das aus ihrer sicht
die richtige strategie also angst machen
vor einer regierung der anderen stadt
eben eigene positionen eigene
überzeugungen heraus zu stellen ja das
natürlich ein sehr zweischneidiges
schwert natürlich muss die cdu
alternativen realistisch sind benennen
und eine realistische alternative könnte
durchaus sagen ein linksbündnis und
beteiligungen wir werden heute
vielleicht dazu näheres erfahren was in
den sogenannten eckpunktepapier der
linkspartei drin steht wenn es eine
parlamentarische mehrheit geben sollte
eine klare parlamentarische mehrheit für
diese drei parteien dann glaube ich
würden sie auch in
koalitionsverhandlungen eintreten
andererseits erwägt die union ein wenig
den eindruck sie sie wolle nun sich
wurden umsatteln zur politikberatung für
den politischen gegner und
selbstverständlich springt weder die spd
noch die fdp noch die grünen über das
klötzchen dass die union ihn hinhalte
als möchtegern politikberater will die
union ja dass spd und grüne einem
bündnis mit der linkspartei schon von
vornherein eine absage erteilen aber
scholz und berbalk wollen kein bündnis
explizit ausschließen die formulieren
stattdessen bedingungen für alle
potenziellen koalitionspartner wie zum
beispiel ein klares bekenntnis zur nato
oder zur europäischen union was glauben
sie was werden diese bedingungen nach
dem 26 september noch wert sein
bedingungen sind immer so viel wert wie
ernst man sie sind und wie leicht es
einem gelingt durch etwas verbalen
glitter die bedingungen verbal
einzuhalten und faktisch aber zu
unterlaufen herr bartsch von der
linkspartei hat ja schon gesagt man
könne in koalitionsverhandlungen über
alles reden bei frau wissler gestern im
fernsehen die eine ehemalige oder
aktuelle trotzkisten ist klang es schon
deutlich unversöhnlicher aber eins ist
klar die linkspartei die ja
gewissermassen wie die jungfrau zum
kinde nun in die aussicht eine
regierungs see gekommen ist sie verliert
stetig in den umfragen und nur weil die
spd ständig steigt und die grünen in
geringerem maße verlieren ist nun ein
rot rot grünes bündnis in realistische
nähe gerückt und diese chance würde
natürlich die würden die funktionäre der
linkspartei nicht tatenlos verstreichen
lassen mal sehen was schon den wissler
und dietmar ratsch nachher nach 10 uhr
auch hier bei phoenix live zu sehen an
vor allem sozialpolitischen kernpunkten
ihrer partei vorstellen werden kommen
aber noch mal zur union zurück herr
kessler armin laschet könnte ja nach dem
jetzigen umfrage stand tatsächlich nur
noch mit hilfe von fdp und grünen ins
kanzleramt einziehen also eben mit einer
jamaika-koalition
der ist christian lindner vor vier
jahren bekanntlich noch davon gelaufen
aber an der fdp wird es wohl diesmal
nicht scheitern oder so regierungswillig
ihr vorsitzender in diesen tagen susan
scheint mir rein theoretisch und dass
die theoretische oder zur gänze
natürlich auch eine deutschland
koalition noch denkbar falls die cdu
doch noch vor der spd landete oder sie
bereit wäre eine juniorpartnerschaft
einzuwilligen aber ist klar jamaika ist
ebenso wie ampel momentan einer der
beiden am realistischsten erscheinenden
optionen der druck auf herrn lindner ist
sehr sehr groß und deshalb versucht er
nun den preis natürlich schon im
vorhinein für künftige
koalitionsverhandlungen hochzutreiben
aber er würde sich der macht das dann ja
immer im politikerdeutsch der
verantwortung der staatsbürgerlichen
verantwortung nicht verschließen und
eben versuchen möglichst viele
fdp-positionen verwirklichen zu können
der wahlkampf könnte auch für alle
beteiligten ein bisschen logistisch
leichter werden wenn jetzt der
bahnstreik tatsächlich kommende nacht zu
ende geht jedenfalls vorerst zu ende
geht muss man wohl sagen was glauben sie
wann und unter welchen umständen wird
der gdl chef claus weselsky bereit sein
wieder an den verhandlungstisch
zurückzukehren tatsächlich erstmal die
bahn praktisch alle seine forderungen
erfüllt hat
na gut dazu müsste ich im kopf von herrn
wir selbst besitzen und ich glaube das
ist momentan kann also schöner ort also
lassen sie es mich schon von außen
bewerten wir sehen natürlich auf diesem
dramatisch eskalierenden bahn kampfbahn
kampf um neue tariferhöhungen wie
schlecht es doch ist das ebenen das netz
und der betrieb getrennt sind in
deutschland die gdl kann halb
deutschland lahmlegen weil es quasi ein
monopol der deutschen bahn ag auf den
netzbetrieb gibt hätten wir mehrere
verschiedene konkurrierende anbieter
konnte man einfach in andere züge sich
setzen hält versetzte eine lange nase
drehen er will das maximale rausholen
das hat er gezeigt im wer zuzutrauen
auch weitere wochen immer wieder
nadelstiche zu setzen irgendwann wird
auch dieser streik zu ende geht und dann
muss man wirklich darüber nachdenken wie
netz und betrieb der bahn zu teilen sind
oder wie sie es eben so schön formuliert
haben einen bahn kampf der im moment
jedenfalls viele opfer kennt herr
kessler danke für das gespräch und
großer nach berlin ich sehr gerne grüße
nach bonn